bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors dix personnes sont
décédées ducobu 19 au cours des
dernières 24 heures ceux qui portent à
129 le nombre total de morts depuis le
début de la pandémie le confinement est
prolongée de deux semaines en nouvelle
calédonie en raison je cite les
autorités d'une circulation trop élevé
du commis 19
comment expliquer cette dégradation de
la situation sanitaire dans l'archipel
je ne sais pas si on peut parler de
dégradation parce que en réalité nous
sommes en plein dans l'épidémie et au
fur et à mesure de l'augmentation des
cas positifs on en est à huit mille et
bien
les malades faisant des formes graves ou
est en réanimation ou décédés augmente
tout à l'heure le communiqué du
gouvernement indiqué que nous sommes à
cent quarante deux décès et
171 malades sont en surveillance
médicale et 52 en réanimation donc on
est en plein dans l'allée dire l'oeil du
cyclone pour utiliser une image qu'on
connaît et chez nous et donc c'est
qu'elle est guère normal hélas que les
indicateurs
font montre eu un état de grande gravité
ouais mais il ya des indicateurs
oui
en comparaison avec d'autres d'autres
départements d'outre-mer à la guadeloupe
où la réunion c'est vrai que la
situation en nouvelle-calédonie
est assez assez tendue en ce moment
oui mais le nombre de personnes qui se
vaccinent
augmente de plus en plus
l'épidémie s'est déclenchée le
confinement s'est déclenchée le 6
septembre et nous sommes le 2 octobre et
déjà les chiffres
encourageant alors justement sur la
vaccination alors ouais
alors seul un tiers de la population est
totalement vacciner sur l'archipel deux
tiers ont reçu la première dose comment
vous expliquer ce faible taux de
vaccination en nouvelle calédonie
et bien il ya une cause profonde c'est
que depuis l'apparition de cette maladie
à l'échelon du monde nous n'avons pas
été touchés donc pendant un an et demi
les calédoniens ont vécu sans qu vide
avec un gouvernement qu'ils avaient à
juste titre se féliciter de notre
système de quarantaine qui éviter
l'introduction du colis
ce qui fait qu'il n'y avait pas d'
incitation forte concret réel à se
vacciner c'est ce qui explique que quand
le convie est intervenue et entrer dans
le pays et bien que deux calédoniens été
vaccinées mais depuis il ya une
augmentation nette et régulière de la
vaccination alors meilleur plusieurs
projections qui sont faits par les
spécialistes du gouvernement et les
délais eux les délais varient entre
novembre et début décembre pour avoir un
taux de vaccination
satisfaisant alors malgré le
prolongement du confinement à la
campagne pour le référendum sur l'auto
détermination reste maintenue mais
difficile on imagine pour les deux
comptes de sa campagne dans ces
conditions est ce que cela peut retarder
selon vous le scrutin du 12 décembre
écoutez on ne le sait pas encore
aujourd'hui personne ne le sait mais
c'est vrai que la question se pose
pourquoi parce que on ne peut pas
décider de cela aujourd'hui parce que ça
voudrait dire que toute la stratégiste
sanitaire ne va pas porter ses fruits
dont le ministre de l'outre-mer vient en
nouvelle calédonie l'asthme prochaine
j'étais venu il ya un an il a dit qu'ils
reviendraient dans un an nous y sommes
et la question du référendum est à
l'ordre du jour deux fois plutôt qu'une
ainsi que les discussions politiques sur
la période de transition et son contenu
après la tenue du référendum donc
il va y avoir la semaine prochaine une
discussion politique et qui va essayer
d'évaluer
les différentes conditions qui
permettent ou non la tenue du référendum
qui est le troisième on doit plutôt dire
une consultation d'ailleurs ça sera le
mot de la fin estime être courte au
beach merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
historien et spécialiste de la nouvelle
calédonie